-Now, Serena, you have one of
the best tennis serves
on the planet,
but I've been wondering,
does that also make you
an expert ax thrower?
So, tonight,
we're going to find out,
because I'm challenging you
to an ax-throwing contest.
We're going to take turns
throwing axes at that target,
which we found in the old
"Tonight Show" prop room.
10 points for the hat,
5 points for the body,
2 for the legs,
and 1 for the hands.
We'll throw three axes each.
Most points at the end
is the winner.
I'll take the first throw.
So maybe stand back.
[ Breathes deeply ]
Yeah. Yeah.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
You slick son of a bitch!
-Oh!
-Oh, yeah, really. Right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-Ahh!
-Geez!
-I mean, you didn't get him,
but you've killed him.
Wow.
All right, here we go.
Focus up. You can do it.
You can do it, Jamesy.
Here we go!
Judges?
[ Buzz ]
Yeah, whatever.
Oh, my God.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Happy dance.
-You let go at the --
-There you go. Now you got to...
[ Laughter ]
That's scarier
than getting hit with an ax.
You just bitch-slapped
him with an ax.
All right. Easy-peasy.
Where do you want me to go?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
The hat?
Yeah, you want me
to go with the hat?
Where do you want me to go?
You want me to go to the body?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Yeah!
[ Laughs ]
Yeah!
-Come on.
You know I took it there.
You can do it for fun, but you
know what's gonna happen. Yeah.
-Man, I loved that
victory dance.
Okay, here we go.
It's in the release.
I don't know how to do this.
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'll give you the win.
I'll give you the win on that.
Serena Williams, everybody!
-Whoo!
-The real champ.